I need help
please
something I'm doing
your
car no sir I
don't I'm
with because I don't know why why are we
being asked if we you have guns well
stop right there first off you're
driving without any tail lights second
off we keep getting reports of people
stealing packages off the porches where
all these boxes come from we were
building gingerbread houses I got them
out the recycling I just stopped right
there and got some from where right
there where I I that just passed the
police
set he's under age he's only 15 okay so
when we go watch these videos from all
the ring cameras of people stealing off
the porches is it going to be him cuz
he's wearing a mask just like the person
in the videos no that's that's cuz he
keeps his hair down so he's wearing a
ski mask cuz hears outside yes it's he
does car why he's the one who does my
delivery driver's license on you no sir
my mom does can I please just have her
no what's your
name Taylor
PS no mommy please come
here I'm sending you my location are all
these boxes empty some of them are which
ones aren't I don't know there was some
in the trunk can we look at him
yes get your info for me yeah no mommy
you open the doors for me what's your
name I'm scared Taylor can I please step
out com just sit down just calm down
Taylor common
spelling t a y l o r mommy please come
here last name last
name can spell your last name for me can
you open the doors for us you could just
pull them I'm
sorry last name please
tayor Nicole yes sit down hold on I need
to breathe I'm sorry I have bad anxiety
mommy can you tell them sit down I'm
trying
to you're not I'm sitting down you need
to start listening I'm trying to sir I'm
sorry Taylor and Nicole my anxiety's
really bad I'm about to
faint Taylor
Nicole yes sir that's your last name yes
sir n i c h o l
e date of birth 1221 1999 all right at
this
point step out for me okay put your
phone right there for me Mommy put your
phone right what's going on you're being
detained as well
mommy your no mommy go to my house come
get my phone your hands together my
boyfriend my dogs put the back your put
the back of your hands can you to my mom
my location please she doesn't need know
your location yes she does how old are
you I'm 23 all right well she don't need
to know Mommy please come give me a
please
Mom I'm going to go run
this see if I can get something for
him yeah D they got like 20 packages in
there sit down right here for me
okay easy all right so I I just
explained to you okay you don't have to
answer questions if you don't want to if
you decide to answer questions you can
stop at any time if you want to talk to
a lawyer before asking answering any
questions you can also do that so right
now the car is being seized uh cuz you
have a bunch of stolen packages in it
okay um he's under arrest and you're
under arrest got it yes sir okay did
well I mean how many houses did you guys
hit I don't cuz you were literally
throwing packages from houses that you
stole from into other houses front yards
no I was not but you're driving I'm
sorry what so what I mean I apologize
sir I don't want to be in any more
trouble I'll do whatever I'm how manyan
you been driving all over town did you
guys just start all night I just started
I promise so how do you know
him I don't know him for real I was
just what's his
name how old is he he's only 15
okay can you please let me know what's
going to happen to me can I get like
sided can I get a bond yes sir I have
work and I have dogs and a kid at home
so why are you out doing this because I
was trying to make my rent money and I
didn't I was scared cuz the lady just
texted me and told me she needed some
money who the rent lady you could go
check my phone she just said she needed
money so how do you know this kid like
how did he get roped into helping you
steal packages because I was helping his
mom asked me to help her while she got
on her feet and so she he was staying
with me but she didn't help me with
nothing and I'm
trying she don't she gets food stamps
for him and everything and I've had them
for like 6 months and she don't help me
and I don't know what to do anymore so
how many houses have you guys hit today
not a lot sir I promise not a
lot I just wanted the least trouble I
return package and everything I just
can't I can't get in trouble I need and
I got to go pay the rent where my dogs
are they're going to be out there
tomorrow and I don't know what to do
that's why I want to talk to my mom I
take a citation and go to court or
whatever it takes I can't go to
[Music]
jail I'm sorry who's at home with your
kids no nobody it's his other brother
it's his brother there's Twins and
they're like kids to me and I shouldn't
have had him out doing this so they're
not your actual kids no I'm trying to
get custody of them their mom said she
was going to go to court for me and she
never went to court for me to get
custody so I've been doing it why would
you get custody of them be because she
asked me for help her with temporary
custody because why because she don't
have nowhere to live and I did but now
I'm not going to have nowhere my dogs
aren going to have
[Music]
nowhere is there a female officer come
here for
search I just need to know if I can get
a what's going to happen can you guys
site me and I get picked up or something
well we got to figure that out you guys
got a lot of packages there we got to
get through we got to figure all this
stuff out you just been following Amazon
driver around no I just was seeing what
houses had packages in certain
areas I didn't even get all of them so
so knowing what you know and knowing
what you guys were doing why would you
start with such an attitude as soon as
this officer tried to pull you over you
clug the door but started screaming what
you're getting pulled over no I I opened
the door and I asked what I was getting
pulled over for and then I realized the
tail lights were off too so I had to put
the I put the tail lights on when I just
stopped right there on the street why'd
you keep driving into the parking lot
because I was trying to get off of the
main road I'm sorry I was always TI when
you get pulled over to get off the main
road sorry all
right so you don't know how many houses
you hit a it was probably like 10 okay I
just don't want to be in trouble I I
don't I do I do whatever I had to do I
just need a citation something El
possible I don't know if that's going to
be the course of action tonight but we
got to figure all that out okay so put
your feet back in there I'm going to
close this door for just a minute can if
you need anything just let that officer
can you get the phone so I can talk to
my mom please not right now we'll get it
for you just minut you call her when you
have the ability to which is not right
now okay here you
go can you try to give me a citation
please I I'm not handling any of
this city of Montgomery stopped you I'm
the city of blue as
know
can you roll my window down
please
please God I do whatever don't do this
to
me
excuse
me please Mommy come give me please
Mommy
excuse
me
can you let me know what's going on yep
you're going back to the Montgomery
Police Department I actually
what do they do at the police
department
investigating what we
do can you get my phone out of that car
if it's being taken please cuz I'm I'm
not going to be able to get the
car where the keys
at there's somewhere in there there's
still some
hey Serge try that car try this to start
it
again all
right do they release you from the
police department what's that do they
usually release you from the police
department what did you say do they
department I'm not sure what they're
going to do I can't give you any
answers regarding that that's completely
their call can you tell me how far of a
drive it is like five minutes
okay hang
on step out and stand right there can't
pull my pants up
sure
all right right there to that Open
Door what's
[Applause]
going you don't have anything on your
purse that you shouldn't
have you guys need anything else from me
no
thank you no problem